Ce que j'aime dans le MoDem,
c'est sa liberté de pensée,
sa liberté de parole.
Bonjour, je m'appelle Marie-Florence Bulteau-Rambaud,
j'ai 58 ans, j'habite Marseille,
je suis adhérente MoDem depuis 2014.
Depuis 2015, je suis conseillère régionale,
élue sur une liste d'ouverture.
Et depuis 2021,
je suis vice-présidente
de la Région Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur.
J'étais précédemment à l'UMP
et comme beaucoup de gens,
je ne trouvais plus au sein de l'UMP
aucune référence à mes valeurs
vraiment fondamentalement centristes.
J'ai trouvé que le MoDem
était la terre d'accueil
qui me convenait le mieux
et 9 ans après, j'en suis toujours persuadée.
Ce que j'aime dans le MoDem,
c'est sa liberté de pensée,
sa liberté de parole.
C'est sa fibre humaniste,
sa fibre européenne,
qui correspondent parfaitement à ce que je suis,
à ce que je pense et aux prémices
de mon engagement politique.
J'ai 58 ans aujourd'hui,
mais je me suis engagée politiquement à 16 ans,
en 1981, au sein du Mouvement des jeunes giscardiens.
Au sein de la Région Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur,
je suis vice-présidente en charge de l'éducation,
de l'orientation, de l'apprentissage et des lycées.
Mes sujets de prédilection
sont ceux qui touchent à la jeunesse
et particulièrement à la formation de la jeunesse,
qu'elle soit en formation initiale
par le biais des lycées ou des lycées professionnels,
ou alors par le biais de l'apprentissage.
Le vrai sujet stratégique depuis 2019,
c’est cette nouvelle compétence des Régions,
c'est-à-dire l'information
sur les métiers et le plus tôt possible,
puisque dans cette nouvelle compétence,
les Régions ont le devoir d'aller
parler d'orientation auprès des collégiens.
Et c'est vraiment là où tout se joue.
Je suis d'une génération
où souvent, on faisait comme ses parents
ou ce que voulaient les parents.
Ça a été un peu mon cas.
J'ai un père qui était scientifique
et du coup, on m'a poussée
à faire des études scientifiques.
À mon époque, l'orientation,
c'était peu ou mal fait ou pas fait du tout.
J'ai fait une licence de biologie cellulaire.
À cette époque là,
s’est créé un BTS de communication et d'action publicitaire.
Donc j'ai quitté une licence pour faire un BTS,
ce qui, bien évidemment,
n'a pas vraiment ravi mes parents.
Et en 2014, j'ai repris mes études
et j'ai fait Sciences Po Aix.